من الصعب ألا ترغب في معانقة والي ، لكن
التقرب من بعض نظرائه في الحياة الواقعية
يمكن أن يكون خطيرًا للغاية
ولهذا السبب يريد هذا الأستاذ مساعدة
الإنسان على التفاعل بشكل أفضل من أي وقت
مضى وهو يصنع جلدًا آليًا
لمساعدة الروبوتات اليوم في كثير من الأحيان  المستخدمة في
المصانع وخطوط التجميع في عام 2017 ،
كان لدى الشركات المصنعة ما يقرب من 85
روبوتًا صناعيًا لكل 10000 موظف في جميع أنحاء العالم
،
ومن المتوقع أن ينمو العرض العالمي للروبوتات الصناعية بنسبة 14
في المائة سنويًا حتى عام 2021 ،
ولكن نظرًا لأن الروبوتات ليس لديها وعي
بنفسها أو بمحيطها ، فإنها
يمكن أن تكون كذلك  خطير عندما يربط المصنع
روبوتًا
، يضعون سياجًا حوله تمامًا ، لذا
نبقي الإنسان بعيدًا عن الروبوت
ونريد بالفعل إزالة السياج للقيام
بذلك د.  ابتكر جوردون تشينج
أول جلد اصطناعي في العالم للروبوتات
مما يمكّنهم من الشعور والاستجابة
للتلامس الجسدي. تغطي أكثر من 13 ألف مستشعر الجسم h1s من الكتف إلى
أخمص القدمين ، واكتشاف القرب من درجة الحرارة
والضغط ، ورأوا بعضًا من
المعنى الأساسي في الإنسان
والتفاعل الآمن  حاولت العديد من فرق البحث
منح هدية اللمس
للروبوتات وفقًا لجوردون ولم
تكن المستشعرات هي المشكلة أبدًا ، لكن
قوة الحوسبة اللازمة لمعالجة هذه
البيانات أثبتت أنها تتطلب
أكثر من 600 جهاز كمبيوتر ، فلماذا أرغب
في حمل 600 جهاز كمبيوتر معي  أحتاج
إلى شاحنة لتتبعني ، لجأت المجموعة
إلى جلد الإنسان لحل المشكلة ، فكل
شخص لديه حوالي خمسة ملايين
مستقبل للجلد ولكن عقلك لا يستطيع استيعاب
المعلومات من كل واحد في نفس الوقت
بدلاً من ذلك يعطي الجهاز العصبي الأولوية
للأحاسيس الجديدة على سبيل المثال أنت  تشعر
بالقفازات عند ارتدائها لأول مرة ولكن في
النهاية ينسى جسمك
أنها موجودة هناك يا دماغ وجسمنا
لقد قمت بتوصل إلى مخطط
لا ترسل إليّ معلومات ما لم يكن
شيئًا مهمًا بالنسبة
لي لأعرفه
مستوحى من النظام ، قام الفريق بدمج
الخوارزميات مع أجهزة الاستشعار المصممة
لنقل المعلومات فقط عندما
تغير قيمهم النتيجة النهائية ، روبوت
يمكنه  الاسترشاد بالكشف عن
الأسطح غير المستوية والاستجابة
للتطبيقات المحتملة للوجود المادي
لا حصر لها ، ستمكن تلك التطبيقات
مستقبلًا من
العاملين في مجال الرعاية الميكانيكية وحتى المرافقين
[موسيقى]